[Music]
today we have on uh
[Music]
it's like what do we have
Jordan knives right now I got these the
other day
[Music]
get ready to get a little stupid Jackie
B what shoes you're wearing today I got
the concepts Air Max ones nice comfy
cool yeah Miss Arena what shoes are you
wearing today all right today I have um
Fuego Haley what are you wearing today
it's got the brown loafer 11s
I was on the feet we got the grade 10
for Jordan 10. all the accolades on the
bottom
heat the quart purple yep mismatched
laces oh you gotta you know hit it with
the hints of the purple yeah yeah what
shoes are you wearing uh these are blue
tint V2 350s it kicks him what do you
have on today dunks these are the uh the
Grays all right what do you have on
today I have one the Nike Air Max Dawn
pink and green
uh do you know what shoes are you
wearing today I'm wearing just basic Air
Force One Shadows today but I got a
little funky pattern uh you know what
shoes are you wearing today uh you know
just some Adventures from the 80s or 90s
and I'm wearing a low Jordan Ones oh
Vince what do we have on today uh we got
the Air Force Ones on and they're like
suede so I figured it was a nice day
Chuck Chuck Taylor 70 All-Stars oh
hey I'm Caroline I'm the director of
House of highlights and I say that Mitch
is cool